question frog men do you think it's
always a bad thing to be thought of as
slightly unapproachable as the leader
yeah so this is another question about
the dichotomy of leadership is another
question about balance and it's
strangely worded question by the way
from this this Scotsman who I know it's
because he uses the question all uses
the word always and usually always is
always a never right when you use those
they usually don't hold up isn't always
a bad thing yeah but then he kind of he
kind of softens the always by saying
slightly on a parcel so so we give him a
fairly low grade on this question but
luckily the the concept of the question
would give him high grade which is is it
is it is it should you be unapproachable
slightly unapproachable
should you be that's the real question
should you be slightly unapproachable as
a leader well there's this is this is a
question about dichotomy the question is
about balance do you want to have people
approach you about every little problem
ratio as a boss do you want to have that
happen know you don't know right do you
want to be the easy button where you
have to answer every single question and
make every decision if you're too
approachable that's where you're gonna
find yourself now at the same time at
the other end of the spectrum do you
want your team to never approach you
ever because you're unapproachable yeah
no you don't want that do you want them
to to be scared or intimidated from
giving you good honest feedback or good
suggestions about the way you're doing
things do you not want that to happen
because you're too unapproachable of
course not so those are the dichotomies
you can be too too approachable and be
the easy button or you can be too aloof
and too distant and too unapproachable
that you don't even know what's
happening on the front lines and you
don't get any input from them the
extremes are bad so what you want to do
is you want to balance those two
dichotomies
be in the middle be approachable but not
overly approachable mm-hmm and you'll be
good